Hey how's it going today is another one
of those days it's so late
oh my god it's so late it's I'm such a
hard worker but I need to record a video
and I got a pretty good one
I remember the to be continued means
pretty pie lice to the mean again you
got me that's hilarious
why did I do that for no reason we're
gonna watch some to be continued memes
cuz they're funny
let's have a look oh boy it's a guy rock
climbing
I wonder what can go wrong here it's
getting ready to jump
I need to know what happened now if you
guys don't know it's this meme can't
came from the anime JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure it's just a cliffhanger this
is literally a cliff cliff jumper am i
right I need to find the original where
do we have it this is the one man
survives
damnit this is the jump this is the jump
this is to jump okay does he make it oh
my god he made it oh my god he made it
how oh I hate it I hate it
[ __ ] idiot I love the adrenaline
[ __ ] [ __ ] cheese I love how it ends
just in that sheer panic moment cuz we
all have that one moment where
everything is fun and games and then all
the sudden oh my god it's kind of like
you can do one when Michael got stuck in
the police car but still oh wow
hey look it's Michael what the [ __ ] was
that
[Music]
that's the shittiest one I've ever
[ __ ] seen what the [ __ ] was that
it's Pokemon it's an evolution
it's gonna smash it thanks good that's
really good Jesus Christ I face it
[ __ ] terrifying no why would you do
that why would you do that why would you
do all right right now I can never trust
a man a kicker an apple off knife
what is that Cole where does that
originate from oh that's right he had to
shoot an apple off his son's head to
save his life
look at that guy's face that's my face
zoom in on this guy that's me
literally me [ __ ] man well you know I
didn't think they could be any shittier
but here we have one we continue you
mean they're the best they're the best
except this one well I seen this one
Taiwan is insane that one is he's
[ __ ] insane I gotta show you guys
that one how do how do these people
survive you know people die from so many
weird [ __ ] random [ __ ] how do they
survive this this one is so [ __ ] cool
cuz cuz sadly everyone lives in this one
why is he hanging on the [ __ ] wind to
begin with oh it hurts it hurts what the
[ __ ] is wrong with people that's cats
can't high five
this is torture I wonder if they land on
their feet though skydive strapped to
her owner she has her own oxygen mask on
goggles but why but why I'm getting a
little sidetracked but why the [ __ ]
would you do that I wouldn't bring
slippy up in the air that'd be kind of
cool
[Music]
part of me just want them to die I don't
know I think part of me has said I can't
see them die these don't okay it's funny
alright but it don't work I saw what
happened
alright but the thing that that you
don't know what happens that's the joy
oh did he die or not clearly he's just
gonna get hurt I want to know if they
die I know it's a little morbid and
weird of me to say that but it's true
it's just gonna easily be like over he's
gonna fall yeah he's gonna [ __ ] fall
in the water and scream like a little
[ __ ]
there's no to be continued there unless
he breaks his leg or some [ __ ] like I
don't care
[Music]
okay that was funny okay that was fun
see that's what I'm talking about
if you don't know if they I mean I'm
sure they died oh let me just take this
second moment also they're just safe
what the [ __ ] Russians what is wrong
with you do you have do not have
internet in Russia to do other things
than jumping off a [ __ ] building why
is that [ __ ] that it's fake cuz he's
wearing a suit if they're made okay I
get it it's fake dammit dammit
I wanted him to die why do we are say
that what's wrong with me see I know
what's gonna happen he shot the shotgun
come on [ __ ] learn how to do these
memes alright oh [ __ ] I'm not funny
he's gonna fall he's gonna fall this
might be good no it's not
I miss it breaks his neck I don't care
okay I don't care
oh no he felt are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
whoever makes stupid [ __ ] this stupid
[Music]
Jesus Christ may I'm reacting to such
[ __ ] all good job okay at least some
people have a sense of [ __ ] human
[Music]
okay fine oh yes I mean no no no haha oh
my god can you have the PlayStation
music - how long does this go on
he's - having a wank isn't he I know
it's a kid but it's still funny okay I
can't wait to have kids just to [ __ ]
with them the plot twists oh [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm so confused I am so confused that
it's me right now alright guys I hope
you enjoyed this video if you did go
ahead and leave a like and check out
another video and as always stay awesome